well first of all it always depends on
definition what is capitalism and and
and so on them you know I'm not a
scientific thing but I would say if the
summary in pragmatic terms of capitalism
was shareholder value and nothing else
then I think this is over without any
doubt I think we don't have to wait for
this is over by now and I don't think
this will come back as i mentioned
before any CEO of this world has
recognized through this crisis that
shareholder value alone is not a
sustainable model and that you have to
be able to combine shareholder value
with the value for society at large so
that's one thing now Hess's changed
enormously perhaps for some companies I
don't think it has changed the look for
Nestle we wouldn't be here 145 years
after having been created successful
growing profitable giving a great return
to our shareholders if we had not had
all the time thought about long term and
about we have to create value also for
society a company is not sustainable if
it doesn't take in such a responsible
manner
well of course my personal perspective
has changed enormously I mean in the
very beginning I was really as a
salesman not very much worried about the
role of the company itself in the
society I was more worried about taking
care of my consumers and my customers
and that's what more or less the horizon
was now very early on that this came
through my exposure of course and Chile
during the area before during and after
yendi I was exposed and very practically
I would say to the role of the offer of
a multinational company in a society
that was questioning its role I mean at
that time in the late 60 in the early
70s multinationals were being considered
as ugly as you said regan could be and I
always remember there was one African
leader who once told me he said well
there's only one thing worse for a
country to be exploited by a
multinational and he said exploited by
multinational and they asked him what
was it he said not being exploited by
nesha by multinational but the dead-time
really i mean multinationals were really
seen as a very ugly thing until I think
society and the multinationals also
through their behavior started to
understand that they have to integrate
themselves into this society so that
this learning process which then of
course was intensified during my years
in Ecuador which was just coming out of
a military dictatorship and had the
first steps into democracy and then
later on in Venezuela which was a
completely different environment where
we were nationalized learnt about what
can lead to national due to a
nationalization of a company that
behaved I saw it very well well
all those things of course have formed
and changed my mindset about the role of
companies and societies and here we are
today and I think having been able to
formulate this concept of creating
shared value I really hope that this is
a certain legacy that I can leave behind
not only for Nestle but hopefully also
for other companies and I was extremely
happy to see that in the annual reports
2009 of several of my competitors
creating shared value was mentioned as a
concept under the title creating shared
value so it shows me that I'm not alone
and that there are many of my colleagues
also share that the real role of the
company is to be at the service of the
shareholders end of the society